your background on how you
all of a sudden decided to want to
research these types of material what
what inspired you want to write and
research obesity code or diabetes code
or now
cancer code yeah that's an interesting
thing because as a kidney specialist
what happened was i went to medical
school in the late
mid to late 1990s and
at the time of course i wasn't really
interested in nutrition that's not
something
doctors really were taught you get
really no training in medical school
and not much in specialty training
either we've got a lot of training in
drugs on how to do dialysis for example
but not not much on weight loss but what
happened of course
is that over that period of time obesity
just became a bigger and bigger and
bigger
problem in the united states so you've
probably seen all the stats in terms of
obesity it's
just basically going straight up since
like the the mid-1970s
and along with that came type 2 diabetes
so people who are
overweight are at much higher risk of
developing type 2 diabetes
and probably the number one cause
of kidney disease by far actually is
type 2 diabetes
so that's really where i started to see
a lot more
problems with um you know the field that
i was in
so it was interesting so i just treated
people the normal way
and but the thing is that it was not
very satisfying
that is people would get their kidney
disease i'd treat them with drugs i'd
treat them with
dialysis and so on and then they'd still
get sick
and eventually it struck me as very
strange the way that we treat
type 2 diabetes and kidney disease
because if the
if the kidney disease is caused by the
type 2 diabetes then the key is really
to get rid of the type 2 diabetes and
the thing that was strange is that
if you went to sort of any standard talk
from a medical
school or university they talk about how
type 2 diabetes was this chronic and
progressive disease
at the same time everybody knew it
wasn't true
everybody i mean not just doctors but
everybody knew it was just
basically a lie because if you're able
to
lose weight then your diabetes almost
always got better and sometimes
completely disappear
so that wasn't random everybody knew it
and
the problem was then not how to treat
people with
drugs the real the real solution is how
to get
them to lose weight so that they don't
get diabetes
so they don't get kidney disease but it
wasn't just kidney disease of course
type 2 diabetes causes heart attacks
causes cancer causes amputations like
it's the number one cause of blindness
it's the number one cause of amputations
you get these diabetic foot infections
that people need amputated there's all
kinds of the number one cause of nerve
damage so it just caused
all kinds of problems those are the
problems that i was seeing in my
patients
and i didn't want to treat them i wanted
them to be better but the only way to do
that was to get them
to reverse their type 2 diabetes which
is possible because we know that
and then therefore they must lose weight
so that's how i got very
interested in the question of how do you
get somebody to lose weight and that's
when i started to look back at the
medical literature because my advantage
is that i could go back and
look through all the literature and of
course the standard advice for weight
loss
was and every doctor every dietitian
would get this advice
they tell people okay well just eat 500
calories less per day
and you're gonna lose about a pound of
fat per week
okay so this is a standard advice that
we gave for the last sort of 35 years
and it didn't work for anybody okay
and that just wasn't my it just wasn't
my opinion right
people were gaining weight people were
getting this advice they're trying to do
it
and then they were not succeeding so
the point is that if you actually look
at um
big databases of how well this advice
worked how how often people went from
sort of being obese to non-obese
the success rate of this sort of
treatment was about 0.5 percent
in other words about a 99.5
failure rate of this advice to just cut
a few calories low eat a low fat diet
cut calories
99.5 chance of failure
like what sort of idiot would give that
advice
that almost never works yeah and the
problem of course was that it wasn't
just medical
every lay person everybody in the
country had practically done one of
these diets
and it almost always failed so that's
why i started looking back at it and
saying look
what's going on here like this is the
stuff that i was
taught i was brought up on and it wasn't
true
and it wasn't true for me either because
i've done these diets and it didn't work
and it didn't work for anybody
so that's what the obesity code was
really going back and looking at this
calories in calories out story that we
had been
fed and trying to look at it from a very
scientific standpoint
and of course the whole thing is just
garbage because
the whole premise of this sort of a
calories is a calories idea
is that you know if you eat a hundred
calories of cookies
and a hundred calories of say an egg
well they're going to be equally
fattening okay
but that's garbage it doesn't it's not
even
true in any sense because
the problem is when you take that food
like you take a cookie and put it in
your mouth
and you take that egg you put it in your
mouth the minute you put it in
the hormonal response of our body our
body responds to that
food completely differently
if it's cookies like carbohydrates or
egg which is fat and protein
completely different response from a
hormonal standpoint
therefore the instructions that we are
giving to our body
from those foods is completely different
so for example you eat a cookie
the hormone insulin spikes way up
okay and what insulin does is it tells
our body to please store body fat
store those calories as body fat that's
its job
that's insulin's job is to tell our body
to do that
so when you eat the cookie insulin
spikes up
all of that 100 calories goes straight
into our fat
deposits that's being stored you eat
that egg
of course insulin does not spike up
nearly as high
and therefore our body can use that
energy he'll use it for different things
or use it to build muscle or use it to
you know burn off because it's not about
the number of calories
because your body when the calories goes
in can either store it
or it can burn it but which one it does
depends
on the instructions that we give our
body which are different according to
the different foods
so you know when people say a calorie is
a calorie it's like of course a calories
a calorie but i never
asked you that question i never said is
a calorie calorie
it's like saying a dog is a dog it's
like so what that's a nonsensical
statement
the question i really want to know
is are all calories equally fattening
and that is not true so the point is
that if
you eat a calorie of um
cookies or if you eat broccoli they're
not equally fattening
right and your grandmother could have
told you that because if you eat cookies
you'll say oh you're gonna get fat
if you eat broccoli nobody ever gets fat
eating broccoli
so that's just common sense right it's
just common sense and it doesn't
dispel the myth of a calorie as a
calorie because the point is
that if if your body has those calories
so you say you eat a cookie
say you take 100 cookies 100 calories of
cookie or you drink a big gulp or
something like some sugary soda
right so you take 100 calories of a big
goal
well the effect on our body is different
one it's going to spike insulin it's
going to go into our fat stores it's
going to store that energy
but it's not going to make you full
right so
if you eat an egg or a little piece of
meat
it will make you full so therefore the
effect on the number of calories coming
in
is totally different the effect on our
bodies whether we store it or not is
completely different
and therefore what we have to focus on
is not the number of calories because we
know that's a
strategy that has failed like not just
once but it's failed over and over and
over and over again right
what we have to do is concentrate on a
strategy
that is going to tell our body to use up
some of those those calories that we've
stored which is just body fat